let's talk about the flight attendant
everybody loves the show it's such a big
hit
it really came out of the gate hot
it connected with people what can they
expect from this season
well i don't want to give it all away i
know but everything is heightened the
comedy the drama the the thriller
everything and you know season one megan
committed espionage with the north
koreans
by the way that would be a cut print
moving on i love espionage that was the
best live reading ever um and so now
she's on the run because she knows that
the north koreans want to murder her and
the fbi and the cia cia want to arrest
her and bring her back to the states for
uh
for high treason
i mean just a day in a life yeah um
but on another note you and your husband
were going to get engaged and there's a
story about the ring
yes
it was after sandy in hurricane sandy he
was stuck in a studio he's a painter and
an artist and a graphic designer sexy
and um
um
so i kept telling him to come home and
and and by the time it was too late so i
didn't know what was happening to him he
didn't know what was happening to me the
next morning he comes home and we're in
the backyard in our pajamas and he just
started crying i go babe i'm okay and he
goes no and he got on his knees i went
oh my god and he proposed to me and he
goes could you say yes my knees are
killing me and um i said yes yes yes and
he goes i don't have a ring and i go
okay how much were you going to spend on
it and he says that's rude i said
i'm just asking you how much are you
going to spend on it and he told me the
amount i go okay i'd rather have a new
kitchen
again i have to high five you
i love that
i love that i love that there's also one
other story i have to ask about you um
have to ask you about
uh something about strong kissing
oh that's so embarrassing i love it
please tell me when i was younger the
boys didn't look at me you know until
these came and um
oh man
and um
you know so i used to practice hickeys
on my arm just in case you know you got
to be ready you got to be ready i love
hickeys you do i love a hickey so much i
really do i hope my hickey days are not
over i don't they're the the not the not
getting caught the knowing it's there
the moment you know it's going too far
and you're like that's gonna leave a
mark
they're so fun
that's weird so um
so uh
so um i used to watch i love classic
movies uh tcm i love right old films i
love it the best yes yeah for classic
movies and you know how they kiss it's
like ah
and they go in so when i kissed my first
guy i went in hard right and i he didn't
say anything he went with it so every
boy kissed after that i would smother
him and like be really forceful and
really hard like
and um then this one guy
this one guy who i really really liked
he went rose rose rose calm down i said
what
he goes what are you you're kissing like
you're you're in a movie i go
yeah and he goes that's not the way it's
done i go no he goes it's soft and i go
i know he goes no you don't and he
kissed me softly and i went
wow
never kiss todd again well i love these
stories i love love i love kissing i
love engagements and new kitchens and
all of the things
[Music]